[Music]
113 questions about evolution
with john perry
evolutionary question number 26
what are essential genes
and how did they evolve
hello my friends and welcome to another
episode of evolutionary questions
today's question comes from aki he asks
hey john are you aware of the latest
research suggesting that mutations are
not as random as we thought
certain genes are less protected by dna
repair mechanisms
it goes on a little bit there but yes
aggie i am aware of that research well
i'm pretty sure i'm aware of the same
thing that you're talking about this
paper published january of 2022 mutation
bias reflects natural selection in
arabidopsis thaliana
arabidopsis thaliana is this plant right
here geneticists have been studying it
for a long time it's a really easy plant
to grow in the laboratory what they
found here is that mutation rates are
extremely slow in essential genes and
something that i want to point out here
is that they're not saying that
natural selection is doing this actively
they're saying that mutation rates
themselves are actually slower in
essential genes i've been seeing a lot
of interesting interpretations of this
on the internet a lot of people freaking
out saying that everything we thought we
knew about evolution is now wrong and so
on that is not the case in next week's
video
i will explain why that's not the case
but that's for next week's video today i
want to talk about essential genes what
are these essential genes and again this
paper says that mutation frequency is
reduced by half inside of gene bodies so
these are protein coding genes and by
two-thirds in essential genes so today
we're going to go over what are
essential genes and how do they evolve
an essential gene is kind of what you
would expect it to be it's kind of what
it sounds like it is a gene that is so
important to an organism that disrupting
its function results in cell death if
you're a single-celled organism that's
just your death in general or if you're
developing fetus developmental failure
and what do i mean there by disrupting a
gene's function what what does it take
to disrupt a gene's function some of
these genes in order to disrupt their
function you have to mutate the heck out
of them lots of mutations or maybe even
a full-scale deletion and that'll
definitely do it right that'll
definitely disrupt that genes function
but some genes are so entrenched such an
essential part of a cell's function and
so important to be exactly the way that
they are that even point mutations
single point mutations can cause a
disruption in these genes these are
essential genes let me give you an
example of an essential gene one of the
most essential genes known in the human
genome the h4 histone gene this is a
protein that it codes for this is the h4
histone protein this little green thing
here this is sort of a rough
approximation of what that protein looks
like in ribbon form and what this
protein does is it combines with other
proteins those proteins bind to dna and
are very important for how dna is
packaged inside of cells instead of
plant cells and inside of animal cells
and so if you mutate this gene the gene
that codes for this protein well that
will change the protein's shape and if
you change that protein shape even a
little bit this whole structure fails
dna cannot be properly packaged inside
of cells and so the cell dies this is an
extremely extremely essential gene how
essential how sensitive is it to
mutation
the histone h4 gene it codes for a
protein that is 102 amino acids long
that green protein we just saw 100
of those amino acids are identical in
both plant and animal cells this
suggests that only two
non-synonymous mutations have survived
in over 1.5 billion years of evolution
because 1.5 billion years ago was when
plants and animals split from each other
that's when they shared their common
ancestor this is an extremely essential
gene other essential genes can actually
withstand a lot more mutation than that
but this is an extremely essential gene
and when we find genes like this it
forces us to ask the question
how did that gene evolve how did
organisms
evolve with only part of that gene or
maybe not that gene at all right i mean
of course there was a point in history
where that gene did not exist how on
earth were organisms surviving back then
if this is an essential gene
it turns out that humans have over
2472 essential genes probably more than
that actually the way that we come to
this number is we do experiments on mice
mice that have a lot of the same genes
that humans have and we've figured out
that
2472 of our shared genes with mice are
essential for the mouse's survival one
of the main ways that you figure out if
a gene is essential or not is you mutate
it and then you see if the fetus will
still develop and of course that's not
really ethical to do with humans so we
do that on mice that means you got to
take that number with a grain of salt
but still how did our ancestors survive
before all
2472 essential genes
evolved it might be worth putting that
number in perspective
humans have uh roughly between 20 and 30
000 protein coding genes 2472
that are essential
that represents about 10 of our protein
coding genes so how did our ancestors
survive before all
2472 essential genes
evolved well
essential genes start out as merely
profitable genes
there are many ways that that can happen
but there's three that i want to bring
up here because they're so important
they're really cool concepts to think
about in evolution so traits that start
out profitable can become essential
through what's called scaffold removing
so other genes will atrophy after the
new gene evolved because they're no
longer needed that new gene does
something that they used to be doing and
so they can then atrophy and once they
atrophy that new gene is essential
entrenchment is another way so mutations
or other adaptations throughout the
genome can build upon the new gene
forming dependencies an example of this
let's say you have a gene that causes
better blood circulation well that
allows for future mutations elsewhere in
the genome that will cause denser body
tissues to form in the organism those
denser body tissues were not possible
until we had good blood circulation now
that they are possible and now that they
exist now that they have evolved into
existence well you definitely can't get
rid of that gene that causes really good
blood circulation because now the rest
of the organism depends on that that's
called entrenchment
and then finally there's niche expansion
the british folks like to call that
niche expansion a profitable gene can
allow organisms to survive in
environments that used to be deadly once
established in a previously deadly
environment a harsh environment that
profitable gene is now essential and of
course
ecological scaffold removal and that's
where a niche where it used to be really
easy to survive in where where the
organism first evolved in
that niche can disappear the population
has evolved a new gene that allowed them
to expand their niche and then the
original niche where they came from that
ends up getting destroyed through some
sort of ecological
you know whatever climate change or
something like that
and so now that that ecological
scaffolding so that
that was there for them to evolve this
new gene in the first place
that's now removed and they're
completely dependent on the new gene and
is absolutely essential for the entire
species now not just that one population
that lives in the harsh environment it's
now essential for everybody all right so
i've given you a bunch of concepts here
and bullet point lists of stuff and i
showed you this histone coding gene
that's essential for humans but talking
about genes which are these molecules
that interact with their environments in
ways that are really foreign to us it
can be kind of hard to follow these
arguments
and so i want to bring this home somehow
first i want to talk about human
civilizations and then i want to talk
about organs how organs actually evolve
the reason i want to talk about human
civilizations is that cities
civilizations they actually develop they
evolve in a way that's very very similar
to the way that biological systems
evolve human civilizations are not very
top-down directed i mean we all vote for
presidents and we have kings and rulers
and all that but civilization is
actually mainly governed by local
interactions things expand and contract
all sorts of unpredictable unguided
things happen so there's a bunch of
processes that we can see in the
development of a civilization that are
absolutely mirrored in biological
evolution or i guess you could say it's
the other way around civilization
development mirrors biological evolution
this is the city of montreal there are a
lot of essential structures
in this city back in 1998 one of the
essential genes you could say of the
city the essential traits of the city
electricity was destroyed
we had a huge huge ice storm several
inches of ice were covering everything
in the city and that absolutely
destroyed power lines there were seven
days of ice that left people without
electricity for 30 days
and it caused total chaos there were
accidental fires as people were trying
to heat their houses with fires and a
lot of people didn't really remember how
to use a fireplace because they hadn't
used it for so long there were
suffocations people getting too much
smoke in their house there was death by
freezing people who just couldn't get
their houses warm enough and the
military had to come in and rescue
people it was insane they would set up
generators at schools and people just go
live in there and camp inside the gym it
was nuts absolute chaos and this is
really interesting to think about
because of course when the territory now
known as montreal was first colonized by
humans they didn't have electricity when
electricity was made available it was
profitable it was not essential it was
not essential to anything eventually
though electricity became essential and
how did it become essential well first
off you have scaffold removal people who
used to know how to light fires in their
fireplaces and they had wood stored to
keep those fires burning well they
stopped storing wood and they stopped
cleaning their chimneys and they stopped
practicing fire building and so you had
all these fires and you had people
suffocating of smoke and so on that was
atrophy scaffold removal you have
entrenchment electricity in montreal has
become absolutely essential because our
heating systems they depend on
electricity most of them not all of them
a lot of transportation depends on
electricity in order to distribute food
to the people you need to run stores and
those stores use electricity to operate
they use electricity to power the lights
and the heaters of those stores and they
use electricity to process transactions
so people weren't able to buy food even
if you wanted to just buy your food in
cash don't use your credit card and
stuff like that well you can't because
you can't get cash because the bank's
not working so everything failed because
of the entrenchment of electricity in
montreal and then last but not least
here you've got niche expansion a lot of
people who couldn't handle fluctuations
in temperature lived in montreal people
who are really old or really sick they
were able to establish themselves in
montreal just fine even though they were
old even though they were sick because
they had electricity there well once
that electricity was removed montreal
became deadly so again traits that start
out as being profitable can become
essential through scaffold removal
entrenchment and niche expansion now
every time i do a lesson about evolution
and i mention cities and i use examples
of cities
i always get creationists who say well
cities were intelligently designed by
humans and of course that is partly true
i mean the city itself isn't really
designed but there is some city planning
which is done intelligently and of
course all of the little inventions and
stuff that we talked about were designed
through intelligence so yeah let's just
go ahead and accept that criticism and
let's look at
biology a couple years ago i did a talk
which i've got a link to it in the video
description over an hour long what
evolved first the brain the heart or the
stomach i'm going to take some slides
from that and i'm going to talk about
the evolution of the heart
which evolved first blood
blood vessels or heart and i'm going to
talk about blood blood vessels and the
heart instead of talking about genes
specifically because
these structures are more relatable to
people than genes
tetrapods which includes reptiles and
mammals and amphibians all the backbone
things that live at least partially on
land we all have very complicated hearts
multiple chambers there's a really
strong muscle in there that's constantly
pulsating it is a very complex structure
and it is essential for our survival and
so the question you can ask is how on
earth did our ancestors survive without
a heart if the heart is essential the
same goes for blood vessels and blood
well if we look at the tree of life if
we do a little bit of comparative
anatomy to different organisms and
different parts of the tree of life
today
we can put together a rough sketch of
what happened how it is that the heart
evolved it's not going to be a perfect
picture of course because the organisms
that are alive today they've been
evolving forever just like we have and
so when we do comparative anatomy even
if we're looking at organisms that are
really distantly related from us on the
evolutionary tree they're not really
perfect representatives of our ancestors
when i look at the flat worm here for
example we did not evolve from flatworms
humans and flatworms evolved from a
common ancestor which would have had
common traits but we can put together a
rough sketch of what happened how it is
that the heart evolved
the simplest animals on our planet are
sponges and sponges live just fine
without a heart the pros of being a
sponge is that the ocean is their blood
their cells are loosely packed and they
don't do much work the cons is that they
they can't live outside of nutrient-rich
areas of the sea the ocean is their
blood and it has to be really
nutrient-rich in order for them to
survive and then of course the con is
that they can't play video games they
don't have much energy compared to other
animals and they can't move around
freely like other animals here i've got
nidarians i don't really want to talk
about them let's look at the flatworm
flatworm also doesn't have a heart it
doesn't have blood vessels it doesn't
even have blood it also uses the ocean
as its blood but on top of that it roams
around searching for food because it can
roam around and search for food it
doesn't need the ocean to be as nutrient
rich as the sponge does like this thing
can actively search out food that said
it does have problems processing oxygen
in order to make sure that oxygen gets
to every one of its cells this organism
is highly limited in size they cannot
get very big if they get too big their
tissues just start dying because they
can't get enough oxygen and
flatworms are
stuck being flat being flat gives you a
large surface area for oxygen to be
passed from the water to your cells
directly that's how they survive without
having blood vessels and a heart if we
move further still closer to tetrapods
in the evolutionary tree we find things
like acorn worms hemichordates they're
actually hollow on the inside and that
allows
their gut so that the green thing here
is the gut of this organism they they
eat food the food goes into their their
little mouth part here that food is
processed by the gut and then particles
are transmitted through this liquid in
the body cavity here the selum it's
distributed to the cells of the body so
being hollow is another way to increase
your surface area just like being flat
is a way to increase your surface area
but being hollow like this allows for a
lot more structural exploration
hemichordates are a lot more diverse in
form than flat worms are
and if we zoom in at the top here
we see that they actually have the
beginnings of a circulatory system there
is a muscle
that
can pulsate in the head of an acorn worm
and that squishes this little bulb here
and that bulb
i've drawn it a little bit more simple
than it is in real life it's actually
kind of a mess of a structure i'm
drawing it here as a tube that just has
a hole at the end it's actually just
the tube itself just kind of opens up
into the ceilum the general body cavity
and there's all kinds of folds in it and
weird little structures
but as the head moves around and as this
little muscle flexes liquid gets sucked
in and squirted out of this tube
and that causes circulation that speeds
up oxygen flow inside this organism's
body and it speeds up the flow of
nutrients inside this organism's body
it's called an open circulatory system
very very primitive if we move up again
getting closer to us organisms with
complex hearts we find lancelits so
these are simple chordates
and if you look at them they have a
closed circulatory system they don't
have true blood yet so i've got blood
vessels blood is in quotes here because
their blood isn't really true blood
there's no blood cells but they do have
vessels and they have a closed
circulatory system forming a big network
of vessels
and these vessels themselves can pulsate
the vessel walls are aligned with muscle
and they can pulsate allowing the
transfer of nutrients and oxygen
throughout the body they don't have a
heart but they have pulsating blood
vessels this circulatory system isn't
super efficient compared to the
circulatory systems of organisms that
have hearts a heart is way more
efficient than this and because of that
these animals also can't get very big
they're very restricted this restriction
is due to their poor circulation which
makes it so that cells can't get enough
oxygen or enough nutrients if the animal
gets too big the heart evolved from
arteries and really small organisms next
up we're going to look at a hagfish
in hagfish we start to see a very strong
division of labor in the circulatory
system instead of having muscles all
throughout the whole thing that pulsate
those muscles have moved pretty much
entirely into a single bulb in the chest
in bony fish we have what sort of looks
like a fork chambered heart in tube form
everything's all spread out
and then in amphibians and other
tetrapods we see that all those sacks
condense into these single
multi-chambered heart that you and i are
all familiar with essential organs
evolve in the same way that essential
genes evolve again an essential gene is
a gene so important to an organism that
disrupting its function results in cell
death or developmental failure and how
is it that essential genes evolve
traits that start out as profitable
genes that start out as profitable can
become essential through scaffold
removal through entrenchment and through
niche expansion just like we can trace
the evolution of the heart and the
circulatory system and we can find that
there are ways where the evolution of
this system would have been profitable
but not essential in its early starting
genes start out being profitable and
then become essential through the
process of evolution and these here are
some of the evolutionary dynamics that
cause that to happen next week i will
finish answering aki's question
if you want to hear that make sure that
you are subscribed and that you hit the
little bell icon
so long for now
you